how do you explain Hitler and Nazi
Germany um just one of the more
recent
aggressive expansions through military
might how do you explain that in the
framework of uh offensive
realism well I think that Nazi Germany
was driven in large part by structural
considerations
and I think if you look at Imperial
Germany which was largely responsible
for starting World War I and of course
Nazi Germany's largely responsible for
starting World War II what that tells
you is you didn't need Adolf Hitler to
start World War I right and I believe
that there is a good chance you would
have had World War II in the absence of
Hitler right I believe that Germany was
very powerful it was deeply worried
about the balance of power in Europe and
and it had strong incentives to behave
aggressively uh in in the late 1930s
early
1940s so I I believe that structure
mattered however I want to qualify that
in the case of Adolf Hitler because I do
think he had what you would call a Will
To Power I've never used that word to
describe him before but it's consistent
with my point that I often make that
there are two Le leaders or there have
been two leaders in modern history who
are congenital aggressors uh and one was
Napoleon and the other was Hitler now if
you want to call that a Will To Power
you can do that I I'm more comfortable
referring to Hitler As A congenital
aggressor and referring to Napoleon As A
congenital aggressor although the were
important differences between the two
because Hitler was probably the most
murderous leader uh in recorded history
and Napoleon was not in that category at
all uh but but both of them uh were uh
driven by what you would call a Will To
Power uh and that has to be uh married
to the structural argument in Hitler's
case and also in Napoleon's case is
there some degree on the human
psychology side that
resentment because of how because of
what happened after World War I
led to Hitler wielding so much power and
then Hitler starting World War II so
this is the The Human Side perhaps the
reason I asked that question is also
because you mentioned the century of
humiliation on the China side so to so
to which degree that
humiliation lead to Hitler and lead to
World War II well the question of what
led to Hitler is a very different
question than the question of what led
to World War II once Hitler was in power
I mean after January 30th 1933 he's in
power and then the question of what is
driving him comes racing to the four uh
is there resentment over the Versa
treaty and what happened to Germany yes
did that matter yes but my argument is
that structure was the principal Factor
uh driving the train in in Hitler's case
but what I'm saying here is that there
were other factors at well as well
resentment being one of them will to
power or the fact that he was A
congenital aggressor in my lexicon uh
certainly mattered as well so I I don't
want to dismiss um your point uh about
resentment so Hitler in particular the
way he wielded the way he gained so much
power might have
been the general resentment of the
populace of the German populace
I think that as a result of um defea in
World War I and all the trials and
tribulations associated with viar
Germany and then the coming of uh the
Great Depression all of those factors
definitely account for his coming to
power I think that one of the
reasons um that he was so successful at
winning over the German people once he
came to
power uh was because there was a great
deal of resentment uh in the German body
politic and he played on that resentment
that surely helped him get elected too
but I think uh having studied the case
it was even more important once he took
over I also believe that one of the
principal reasons that he was so popular
and he was wildly popular inside Nazi
Germany is because he was the only
leader of an industrialized country who
pulled this country out of the
depression uh and that really mattered
uh and uh it made him uh very effective
it's also worth noting that he was a
remarkably charismatic individual uh I
find that hard to believe because every
time I look at him or listen to his
speeches uh he does not appear to be
charismatic to me but uh I've talked to
a number of people who are experts on
this subject who assure me that he was
very charismatic and I would note to you
if you look at public opinion polls in
Germany West Germany in the late 1940s
this is the late 1940s after the Third
Reich is destroyed in
1945 he is still remarkably popular in
the polls Stalin is still popular in
many parts of Eastern Europe yeah yeah
and Stalin's popular in many quarters in
inside
Russia uh and Stalin murdered more of
his own people than he murdered people
outside of the Soviet Union and still to
you the ties of History turn not on
individuals but on structural
considerations so so Hitler may be a uh
surface
layer characteristics of how Germany
started a war but not the really the
reason well
history is a multi-dimensional
phenomenon so I hear and we're talking
about Interstate relations here yes and
realism is a theory about how States
interact with each other and there are
many other dimensions to International
politics and if you're talking about
someone like Adolf Hitler right uh why
did he start World War II uh is a very
different question then why did he uh
start the Holocaust or why did he push
forward a holocaust I mean that's you
know a different question and realism
doesn't answer that question so I want
to be very clear that you know I'm not
someone who argues that realism answers
every question about International
politics but it does answer what is you
know one of the big if not the biggest
questions that IR Scholars care about
which is what causes security
competition and what causes great power
War does offensive realism answer the
question why
Hitler attacked the Soviet Union Yes
because from a military strategy
perspective you know there's pros and
cons to that decision pros and cons to
every decision the question is did he
think that he could win a quick and
decisive Victory and uh he did I mean as
did his generals it's very interesting I
I've spent a lot of time studying German
decision making uh
in World War II if you look at the
German decision um to invade Poland on
September 1st 1939 and you look at the
uh German decision invade France on May
10th 1940 and then the Soviet Union on
June 22nd
1941 what you see is there was actually
quite a bit of resistance to Hitler in
1938 at the time of Czechoslovakia
Munich and there was also quite a bit of
resistance in September
1939 internally or you mean internally
internally for sure yeah people had
doubts they didn't think the ver was
ready and given the fact that world war
one had just ended about 20 years before
the thought of starting another European
war was not especially attractive to
lots of German policy makers including
military
leaders and then came France 1940 in the
runoff up to May 10th 1940 uh there was
huge resistance uh in the uh German Army
to attacking France uh but that was
eventually eliminated because they came
up with a clever plan uh the manstein
plan if you look at the decision to
invade the Soviet Union on June 22nd
1941 which is the only case where they
fail they succeeded in France they
succeeded in Poland they suceeded uh at
Munich in
1938 Soviet Union is where they fail
there's hardly any resistance at all
right yeah well and to say that they
failed the Soviet Union I mean my
grandfather F I mean from from the
Soviet Union you know there's a lot of
successes early on so there's poor
military I would say uh strategic
decisions along the way but it was uh it
caught Stalin off
G maybe you can correct me but from my
perspective terrifyingly so they could
have been successful if certain
different decisions were made from a
military
perspective yeah I I've always had the
sense they came terrifyingly close to
winning uh you can make the opposite
argument that they were doomed uh but I
I'm not terribly comfortable making that
argument I think the ver Mo by the
summer of
1941 was a finally tuned instrument for
War and the Red Army was in quite
terrible shape uh Stalin had purged the
officer Corp uh they had performed po
poorly in Finland uh and uh there were
all sorts of reasons to think that they
were no match for the Vermont and if you
look at what happened in the initial
stages of the conf conflict that proved
to be the case uh the Germans won a lot
of significant tactical victories early
on and if they focused and went to
Moscow as quickly as possible it's again
terrifyingly so could have been a
basically topple topple Stalin um and
one thing that's that's possible that's
possible fortunately we're not going to
run the experiment again but one could
argue that that had they concentrated as
the generals wanted to do in going
straight for Moscow that they would have
won I mean what Hitler wanted to do is
he he wanted to go into the Ukraine I
mean Hitler thought that the main axis
uh there were three axes the northern
axis went towards Leningrad the central
axis of course went to Moscow and then
the southern axis Army group South uh
headed towards Ukraine and deep into the
caucuses and Hitler believed that uh
that that should have been the main axis
and in fact in 1942 the Soviets excuse
me the Germans go back on the offensive
in
1942 this is Operation Blue and the main
axis in 42 is deep into the Ukraine and
into the caucuses and that fails but one
could argue that had they done that in
41 had they not gone to Moscow had they
gone you know had they concentrated on
going deep into Ukraine and into the
caucuses they could have knocked the
Soviets out that way uh I'm I'm not sure
that in the end I believe that I I think
in the end the Soviets would have won no
matter what but I'm not 100% sure of
that so sometimes um maybe you can
educate me but sometimes you know they
say just like when Napoleon winter
defeated Hitler in in Russia
I think not often enough people tell the
story of the the soldiers and the the
motivation and how hard they
fight so uh it turns out that ukrainians
and Russians are not easy to conquer
they're the kinds of people that don't
roll over and fight bravely there seems
to be a difference in certain people
peoples in how they see War how they
approach War how proud they are to fight
for their country to die for country
these kinds of things so I think Battle
of staling gr tells at least to me a
story of extremely Brave fighting on the
Soviet side and that it's a component of
War too it's not just structural it's
not just military strategy it's also the
humans involved but maybe that's a
romantic notion of war no I I think
there's a great deal of Truth in that
but let's just unpack it a bit in the
case of the Soviet Union in World War
II the counterargument to that um is
that in World War One the uh Russian
army
disintegrated uh and uh if you look at
what happened when Napoleon invaded in
1812 and you look at what happened in
1917 and then you look at what happened
between 41 and
45 the Napoleon case looks a like the
Hitler case and it fits neatly with your
argument but World War I does not fit
neatly with your argument because the
Russians lost and surrendered yeah and
you had the infamous Treaty of BR lovk
where the Soviet Union then because it
went from Russia to the Soviet Union in
October 1917 the Soviet Union
surrendered large amounts of uh Soviet
territory because it had suffered a
humiliating defeat my argument for why
the Russians let me take that back why
the Soviets fought like wild dogs in
World War II is that they were up
against the genocidal
adversary you want to understand that
the Germans murdered huge numbers of
Soviet
PS uh the overall total was 3.7 million
and by December December of 1941
remember the invasion is June 41 by
December of 194 1 uh the Germans have
murdered 2 million Soviet PS at that
point in time they had murdered many
more PWS than they had murdered Jews and
this is not to deny for one second that
they were on a murderous Rampage when it
came to Jews but they were also on a
murderous Rampage when it came to Soviet
citizens and Soviet soldiers right so
those Soviet soldiers quickly came to
understand that they were were fighting
for their lives if they were taken
prisoner they would die so they fought
like wild dogs yeah you know the story
of the Holocaust of the 6 million Jews
is often told extensively if uh Hitler
one conquer the Soviet Union it's
terrifying to think on a much grander
scan than the Holocaust well what would
have happened to the Slavic people to
the to the Soviet people absolutely well
you have to do is read The Hunger plan
right and they also had had a plan uh
what is it called Grand planned East I
forget the exact name of it uh which
made it clear that they they were going
to murder many tens of millions of
people and by the way I believe that
they would have murdered all the Poes
and all the Roma I mean my view is that
the Jews were number one on the
genocidal Hit List the Roma or the
gypsies were number two and the polls
were number three uh and of course I
just explained to you how many PS they
had killed so they would have ended up
murdering huge numbers of Soviet
citizens as well but people quickly
figured out that this was happening
that's my point to you and that gave
them needless to say very powerful
incentives to fight hard uh against uh
the Germans and to make sure that they
did not win